if there's anyone who's gone through
like we've talked about we've talked a
lot about you know toxic online culture
a lot on our podcast but if there's
anyone who's been through toxic online
culture it is you so if there's someone
we could we could actually take advice
from it's probably you you advice oh
you've been on like you've been online
nothing's inherently wrong but like
you've been on the Forefront of
literally every war or battle when it
comes to that side of things on the
internet yeah you are so it's like I
don't know it's just I think it'd be
really interesting to hear from your
perspective about like what you've seen
and what you've gone through yeah and
like your honest opinions on it yeah
sure
um
where do I even start how do you begin
like for starters again I think I was
really naive right I came on Twitch just
to make friends to play video games with
because in this small town I knew like
two people two girls and like four guys
that I would game with sometimes yeah
that's why we started making YouTube
videos as well yeah I'm friends yeah
exactly and like the two girls didn't
even play games anymore and I'm like I
need Flint you know I was 17 just wanted
to have fun right and I kept doing it uh
part-time and I have been on the
internet since I was like 11 or 10. yeah
yeah like I know that there will always
be some weird comments oh yeah creepy
person some whatever so I was very
accustomed to that and I grew up with an
older brother so I was very used to
bullying I'm kidding not bullying but
like if anything a lot of banjo like he
would talk some [ __ ] I would talk some
[ __ ] yeah now we're besties who play
Valerie together but
um so like I guess I was just very used
to that yeah um so streaming I didn't
like especially just starting off I was
like oh this is normal you'll get weird
comments here and there yeah but oddly
enough I feel like let me know if you
guys agree like way back in the day
before
all these social platforms twitch and
content Creation in general blew up I
actually feel like the internet was a
little more uh like almost like
wholesome and welcoming because there
weren't as many people yeah that deep
into it yeah yeah I was just about to
say it really felt like all the um like
around 2015-16 when obviously all the
political stuff was happening it kind of
just shifted into the online thing yeah
like yeah with all the me too staff as
well where everyone had to pick a side
with it so it was just it became this
you versus them and then if you were a
woman online who had uh yeah yeah and
then there so I imagine that was that
when it started picking up absolutely
but like when I was even like 12 13 14
15 and I would make friends online and
someone found out I was a girl they were
actually really nice yeah so nice
guys your memory of playing maple story
and meeting a guy one time and he was
like well I'm gonna quit and he found
out I was a girl and he gave me all his
loot everything he had been grinding for
like three years and he was like well
I'm actually quitting today that is the
most maple story yeah
yeah
that was my that was probably my first
like simping interaction
and I could tell in that moment I was
like I think he's treating this me this
way because of my gender but it's very
nice so I'll take it oh yeah I mean as a
as a former Maple Star as well yeah I
can I can like attest to that being like
because you know everyone would play the
game and obviously you could pick like
your advertising one though but it was
yeah an actual rare occurrence when it's
like you're your female character and
you're a female IRL legit like girls
were like unicorns in the gaming yeah
yeah but in the way where we were like
treated much nicer because we were rare
yeah exactly exactly I don't know how
this went so South you know as a former
League player how many times the jungler
camp your lane just when they found out
you were a girl actually
I had I guess a different experience
because people get very angry
um and if anything that was when I
started feeling like oh my gender is
something to be used against me like
yeah oh if you're not playing well it's
because of this part of you like oh my
genitals dictate how good I am over the
game odd but sure right um yeah so I
think that's when it like really first
started for me but also with League I
would play a lot with friends and I kind
of chalked up a lot of negative
experiences to like oh just random angry
people online let's just leave that's
that's just the league experience at the
end of the day you'll get there right
you you were like diamond rank right
dude when I grind it I was pretty funny
like I sold you to like D1 or something
honestly as well yeah but like way back
in the day and the thing is like when
you're a casual player yeah and like
these are the streams you know you have
like taller one yeah double live yeah
Pokemon you know when I'm being compared
to these guys who are obviously like
insane and I'm like a casual player like
trying my best above average but like
you have bad games D1 is better than
your entire chat there probably at that
point like do you want people to see you
have a bad game they're like this is my
opportunity to say it's because you're a
girl no dude it's because I'm a casual
player and everybody has bad games all
the time like yeah you're not at your
Peak capabilities 24 7. yeah and
streaming
yeah like how much pressure was on you
as like one of the top like the top
female streamer for like a while to like
feel like you had to be like the perfect
person like the perfect role model even
though you're human just like everyone
else
a lot
and sometimes still to this day it's
just a little bit tough because I feel
like I have to overthink a lot of the
decisions that I make in order for it to
reflect well yeah on this group an
entire gender if anything that I am
unintentionally representing yeah so
like when I decide to do something
um even if it's something as simple as
like I went from playing League to doing
like variety content yes if I don't work
my ass off to make that transition work
well in my favor like oh like finally
she like fell off or this or that you
know you can just people it's hard to
celebrate your food yeah like they're so
ready to write whatever negative
narrative you have to work so hard to
create a positive one for example like
when I first started streaming I saw a
lot of people
um
like a lot of people when a girl was
doing well they'd be like oh it's
because you're dating this person yeah
so they would attribute that female
streamer's success to their partner so I
was like okay I'm never gonna date
anyone publicly that way anything I do
will be accredited to me yeah I thought
no they will just find another way to do
it yeah yeah yeah exactly and instead it
became like a who is she dating she's
hiding her boyfriend for donations and
subs and this and that and I'm like I'm
either doing this
I'm either like clout chasing if someone
is more popular than me or if someone
was less popular than me I'd be using
him if I had him involved you know like
all your pandering to like The Simpsons
or something right yeah anything you do
can be seen negatively that's really
what I've learned there's like time on
the internet so how do you stay positive
then it sounds like everybody
yeah do you just like I guess it's just
like you just stop giving a [ __ ] I guess
it's like
actually but honestly what helped me a
lot was
um my female streamer friends like if I
didn't have them validating me and being
like no like from an objective
perspective telling me there are
instances like obviously I mess up and I
apologize for the situations where I do
mess up yeah but I feel like so many
things get like convoluted taken out of
time yeah yeah yeah
narratives being spread like wildfire to
make me look bad if I didn't have other
people that I trusted objectively saying
like no you are being treated unfairly
in comparison to other people in similar
positions yeah I would have gone crazy I
would like gas myself to heck but
luckily I did have like a really really
great support system okay and I think
like once I got to a point where I
realized oh wow this is like a male
dominated field look at the podcast
you guys are the good ones
that's a good one a good one it's
because we're not in L.A that's my thing
it was also like there's been so many
weird moments in this industry for
example even realizing like
I especially need the help of other like
men in my field male content creators
male streamers yeah because and as
unfortunately misogynistic as this is a
lot of the audience will only really
trust something if it's coming from
another guy that they respect so we need
you guys to say women good for me to be
good
okay
women good guys guys women good yeah
yeah guys we all agree with that right
right Connor is that really the case oh
yeah and it's especially
um
[Applause]
yes in particular there's like so much
to go off of not just that yeah but
knowing that and that being very very
clear to me multiple instances it made
me especially sad when this whole like
narrative became a thing yeah right
because then I could very much sense my
male friends were having a hard time
standing up for me or defending me in
situations because they didn't want to
be deemed oh you're just a Sim you're
this you're the end look down yeah so
there was yeah there was just like my
God forbid platonic relationships God
forbid you say something good about a
girl yeah I think I found weird about
that is that there seems to be like okay
let's say if uh if if a woman actually
was trying to push the the boyfriend
experience and trying to push that yeah
it's not like guys don't do it inversely
yeah yeah I've never really found I
found really we is because as a guy I
see other sometimes I see other content
creators really going for that angle of
like I'm I'm like I'm gonna be your
boyfriend or I'm you know giving you
that experience it's not like there
aren't male creators doing or pushing
even further for their whole boyfriend
experience of like I love you so much
you guys mean so much to me and yeah oh
by the way here's my here's my 30 minute
ASMR with me telling me how much I love
you and it's like people like would
never ever ever criticize people who do
that publicly but it's for some reason
it's okay when it's a woman I don't
understand that's another major
realization that was very helpful to me
because for a long time I was like am I
doing something wrong like people saying
that but I'm like I don't think I go out
of my you don't even yeah you don't yeah
like do that kind of I just love gaming
um I love to do whatever kind of sorry
whatever kind of content I happen to be
in a very male dominated field and then
I realized like wait a second like so
many very very very popular guys have
feel female majority audiences yeah and
no one ever uses that as an insult
towards them yeah or uses that to
describe
just the filthy double standards all
right it's just like oh it's it's like a
low-key blew my mind because I'm like
especially like most male artists think
Justin Bieber when he was young or even
BTS now or like maybe even some male
streamers as well yeah and another thing
is like a bad thing yeah another thing
as well is like you you are it's
recently the v-tubing trend has like
popped off right I remember especially
in the early days of youtubing they were
definitely like it's if if they were a
3D go you know you you know we don't sit
for the 3D girls but it's fine to like
simp for the 2D girls right and it's
fine for the YouTubers like some of the
really early YouTube is to really play
that up you know oh yeah yeah and like
nowadays now it's it's it's the male
YouTubers that are playing it up and
it's completely okay oh yeah I never
thought about it now now it's like you
know yeah like some even in Japan like
some of the top uh V tubers in some
Industries now are male oriented with
massive female or audiences because
obviously you know the idol culture is
massive in Japan right and no one bats
an eye meanwhile 3D streamer who's a
female does it and everyone loses their
minds right yeah I always thought oh
sorry gotta go for it I also think maybe
one of the reasons why is because I feel
like v-tubing and YouTubers in general
um appeal to an audience to whom like
that maybe isn't as weird or they're not
like as ready like if you watch anime
there probably is a waifu that you love
right right um so for that to be a v
tuber instead and be a streamer like
that's probably a cool experience for
you whereas when it comes to gaming over
time I learned there are you know a lot
of people that might tend to be more
misogynistic I don't know the right way
to see these to say these things that
also happened to just heck and love
gaming but those types of people don't
really like anime so they won't go and
hate on a popular YouTuber right because
their interest is gaming not anime
guys are so worried about being like
what the [ __ ] I didn't do anything I'm
not misogynistic and so when they when
you it's hard to have these
conversations because a lot of guys feel
attacked when they're like oh you're
successful because you're a male and
it's like no no that's not what we're
saying it's it's different it's you are
more likely to be successful because you
are a male because of a number of
factors and yeah and you can't deny that
as a male you would have advantages in
certain areas like that's just how life
is that's how like Society has been made
society we live in a society Society
that's just how it is right and to not
accept that and be willing to be like
hey that's what it is but [ __ ] it I can
I can still make sure I can do my own
thing yeah if there's something I don't
addict to people what's wrong with that
nothing wrong with calling it out here's
how it is yeah did you ever feel like
because there was a point where I feel
there was like so much pressure on you
that like you said you it felt like
you're in a like a lose-lose situation
right where you know the you know a lot
of the guys were being like you know
trying to discredit you your if anyone
tried to defend you they were like
labeled as a simp or something like that
and I I feel like you even got a lot of
criticism from like a lot of girls like
being like Oh no this is she's
representing girls wrong where she's
like bringing a bad name for you know
female streamers and stuff like that I
actually feel like that's one of the
things I got the least of
okay okay but really not that often if
anything the girls were one of the
things that kept me going yeah I feel
like no one better understands the
struggle than other female streamers
than others in that game then you know
or really any minority within gaming
kind of understands what that what that
experience is like and the craziest part
of all of this and the Sim stuff is
whatever it's like any time I like pull
my twitch audience or like really get
any analytics from that I have way more
female yeah like gender not uh
non-binary or any other kind of dude
um statistics then the majority of male
streamers right right so make it make
sense